i always knew i started finding guns
you know when you're a kid and you snoop
you always find the gun
that's why kids shoot themselves these
[__] always find guns
and i would snoop and i would find
[__] guns with silencers and
38s and 45s these big [__] things and
he had a collection of knives under his
bed
and that was his specialty so i always
knew something was up
we were at a santeria party one night at
148th and broadway
his nickname was juan four wins cuatro
oriento they called him that from cuba
because he had four brothers
and they said when him and his brothers
were around [__] would [__] go down
like they were really [__] crazy so
they got the nickname four wins
if you didn't know him you weren't
allowed to call him that dog you
couldn't go up to him go hey four wins
he'd pull you aside and go you don't
know me that well [__] my name is juan
okay he was one of those [__]
like he couldn't even get on that level
with him
four wins was for his friends and his
family that's it
i'd even call them four [__] wins
that's how scary this [__] was
i wouldn't even call them four wins i
would always my mother would take a ride
by herself because my mother didn't
drive she took a cab and i would always
go out with him at night
we'd go meet my mother but he'd drive
it'd just be me and him in the
electorate 225.
and one night we go up to this [__]
party but it's like a year later i'm
about eight
we go to the santoria party it was my
godmother she's a cuban lady
and we're up there and they're cutting
the chicken heads and dancing into one
room
and we're in the hallway it's about 2 30
in the morning and we're in a hallway a
skinny hallway and i'm standing next to
him
and my mother my godmother and some
other lady and her husband are in the
kitchen
but the guy is drunk and
the santeria party was in there now
another thing juan had a guy that he
would pay to drop guns off for
because he was on parole so he never
wanted to carry a gun so he would go dog
i'm going to be at the ice house at 8
30. do me a favor
bring the gun to the ice house and leave
in the trunk of your [__] car
he would come in the morning with
somebody and drop a gun off
so he would have like a gun if he had to
run that way he'd have a gun on the
corner
and if he had to run this is how crazy
his [__] was if he had to run
this way he'd have a car
until today i mean he died in 2006 but
until he died you couldn't have a
conversation with him
next to a phone even if the phone was
hung up
in the other room he didn't trust
nothing he didn't like [__] phones
always a lot of bookmakers talk on the
phone he refused to do it
come see me and i'll put the number for
you even if you don't have the cash but
don't call me on the phone
he hated all that this guy was careful
to the t after he got busted that time
he learned this lesson
he was careful to the teeth numbers you
got to write them down if they catch you
with that sheet
that's a [__] charge he would write
microscopically
i couldn't even tell that the paper
would be this big and he'd have like 92
numbers on there that he would decipher
on his own this is a genius and he would
roll it up
and put in the bumper of his car so if
the cops came they could shake him down
to be in the bumper this is the [__]
early 70s way before
these crack guys invented the bumper he
invented that [__] bumper
and the tree on the neighborhood he put
a string on it with money or a gun in
the [__] patch with a tree this
[__] was one of those guys
so we go to the santeria party that
night i didn't see the guy that dropped
off his guns
so i thought we were cool a guy probably
has a knife on him he would wear those
uh
painters pants and he would put the
knife the the straight razor and this a
[__] straight razor that's what he
went out with every night
so we're at this party it's about 2 30.
he's in the hallway with his glasses on
reading this book
and this guy is saying [__] in the
kitchen ah four wins you ain't [__]
and cube i would have [__] you up
another gift he had he would play death
he would always play death but he was
listening [__] he was listening
tight
he'd always make believe like what did
he say what did he say i don't
understand english he understood
everything this [__]
and the guy kept saying [__] and finally
he kept looking at me going what's this
guy saying
and my mother's talking louder so the
guy won't so juan won't hear him my
mother's trying to talk a lot because
this guy is drunk
and my father's looking at me going what
does [__] say and i'm like hey
say no let's get out of here i got his
hand
i go let's go home [__] it leave my mom
here [__] that [__] let's get out of
here right
finally a guy says something and i seen
him look up he took the glasses off
he threw the [__] thing down and i
seen him walk towards the back room
and my godmother knew something because
that [__] got up
and ran after him and once i seen her
running
i went in the kitchen to go ma
something's going down we're crazy man
it's about to go down with this [__]
knucklehead so my mom and the wife take
the guy and they're like come on you
gotta go
and the guy's yelling down the hallway
and i look up and i see my stepfather
coming out of this [__] room with a
45 like a puerto rican on the fifth like
this up in the air
where is this [__]
and my godmother's holding on to his leg
and she's going down in flames
she's just like one one and he's like
get up
and i'm like this last [__] defense
i'm like i'm like no
no no he's like okay let me just talk to
this guy and we'll go right home
he took me by the [__] hand we went
right out there the guy was still out
there with all the people from the party
and he's like [__] you [__] what
the [__] in spanish your mama
binga he's saying all this [__] to my
stepdad
you ain't [__] in cuba i would have
[__] you up mama my lapenga
and my father comes out that 45 and he
goes what'd you say the guy goes you
ain't [__]
if you're a man you'd shoot me right
[__] here boom
boom one shot i'm ah
[__] thought he was he was
[__] with the wrong dude that night
there was no alcohol this guy just shot
him he said [__]
boom ah guy went down my government was
like why'd you shoot him i had to shoot
him
he goes right up to the guy he goes you
say something to the cops i'll [__]
put three bullets in your head turn
around
grabbed me by the hand and we walked to
his colleague we were in disneyland
he got in the car we made a right we
were parked on broadway in 147 we made
it right we went down to
riverside drive he went down like three
blocks we've seen the cop lights coming
up
he pulled over he took the gun and threw
it in the hudson river
we got back in the gun went home he made
a banana shake when we got home
and while we were drinking he goes don't
ever repeat that to nobody
i was like god damn dad you are a heavy
[__] duty [__] the next
morning i got up at my mom at breakfast
nobody said dick everybody was just
eating